you just spent three months on broadway
that has always intrigued me i've always
thought
you know someday i'd love to even have a
small part in a broadway show just to
say i was on broadway you just did
three months on broadway as sally bowles
yeah okay in cabaret yeah
great part right fantastic part it's an
unbelievable part yeah
it's a tough part it's tough yeah it was
um it was
it was really really incredible and and
kind of ridiculous to think you can do a
musical
eight times a week for three months
that's when you've never done a musical
you've never done it before
but the answer is always to say yes i'll
just do it do it jump in and you're
you're very talented but like a lot of
performers you do
eight shows a week you have trouble with
your voice yes and i heard that on one
of the nights
that you lost your voice who shows up to
sit in the audience
but meryl streep meryl streep right
meryl streep venus you've heard of
meryl streep yes yes i think ward is out
she's a she's an actress
she's an up-and-coming actress she's an
upstart slowly learning her craft
very slowly uh but you i would think if
they
came backstage and said meryl streep's
in the crowd that would be scary enough
yeah but it's the night that your voice
is gone was she
nice about the fact that you had lost
your voice the night my voice was gone
as if this wasn't like 40
of the time oh really a lot of the time
a lot of the time
my voice blew out a lot but yes she was
there she was there
and i was actually trying to sneak out i
was just i just got my clothes on i was
like she's going to come you know
backstage and be
kind and generous and lovely because
she's meryl streep and that's part of
who she is i'm sure and so i was just
trying to get my clothes on
and then she came backstage and then i
just started to cry
because i was like oh meryl streep is
here and i couldn't sing anything and
she was so nice and she said i said i
you know my voice was so terrible and
she said
i thought it was just from the cocaine
valley bowls does a lot of cocaine and i
said no
it's because you know i'm terrible and
she was like well you should cultivate
that
really cultivate that she's a great
sense of humor she's hilarious yeah
she's hilarious that's wonderful you
took steroids for your voice
i did and that can have i mean it's
great it actually reduces the swelling
yeah
the vocal cords but it makes you feel
like superman yeah but it also has
other side effects like what like
sleeplessness that was a problem that
was a big problem
and also you're crazy you're just
legitimately
like no holds barred a crazy person on
steroids or at least i was what was so
what was the
uh how did that play itself out in your
life you're up
all night and you're crazy i was up all
night and crazy
well thankfully i didn't do anything too
insane
other than i read online about making
your own
body this is not even very exciting i
mean i was like your own body
well the minute you say that i'm
intrigued
you're making your own what you're
making your own body lotions
and i went on amazon and i bulk bought
everything you would need to make your
own
skincare products so now i have an
but i never did it because what
it's gross it's gross and why why i'm
gonna stir up a vat of lotion
who are you yeah yeah what are you i'm
not burt's bees
yeah i know you know it's true it's
weird i mean there are more embarrassing
things you could have done if you were
up all night like we've all been up
night and in an altered state and bought
things on the internet right and then
they show up later on right
and that's and that's fine christmas
it's like christmas where'd this come
from yeah oh wait
right right yeah yeah yeah he could have
been like i pooped in the street
but no
there's still i don't think i
i did have half a red bull backstage
though oh you did you never know
all right all right you know we've
talked about this going terribly for no
this is going great for my for my
purposes it's going perfectly whenever
we're getting all kinds of
whenever a guest says i pooped in the
street that's an a-plus
yeah i did not poop in the stream yeah
yeah yeah you said it again
there we go all going to be taken out of
it
either way your publicist is horrified
backstage
and the stone says i didn't poop in the
streets gang that's not good either